GABE WEISS: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see
Building IoT Applications
on Google Cloud, stay tuned,
because here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Building an entire
end-to-end IoT application
can feel overwhelming.
What devices should I use?
How do I send my data?
How do I make sure that
everything's secure?
Once data gets somewhere, how
do I get it into a Datastore?
And once I have
it in storage, how
do I actually use the data
to do anything useful?
Half the battle
in creating an app
is just knowing
what technologies
are right for the job.
This is a pretty typical
architecture diagram
for an IoT application built
on Google's Cloud platform.
This diagram even has
a lot going on in it.
But don't worry,
it's all right, I'm
going to walk us through it.
On the topic of
devices themselves,
I'm going to hand
wave a little bit.
Anyone that's done
IoT already knows
there's a lot of debate
going on right now
around hardware choice,
what sort of communication
protocol you want to choose,
what data protocol is the best
one to use?
Most of the time,
some external factor's
going to make this choice for
you, like you need devices
on the side of a mountain.
So pick whatever works
for the environment
that the device lives in.
And now that you've
got your hardware,
you need a good way to
keep track of all of them
and connect them to
the Cloud securely.
This is what Cloud IoT
Core is designed to do.
It's a managed service and acts
as a gateway for your devices
to Google Cloud Platform.
It handles registration of
devices, securely connecting
and communicating with
them, and can even
do things like send
configuration messages back
down to your devices.
Once your devices are sending
their telemetry up to IoT Core,
these telemetry
payloads get bridged
into our event stream manager--
Cloud Pub/Sub.
Events only stay on
Pub/Sub for seven days,
so we need to move them out of
there into permanent storage.
To do that, we pick
Cloud Functions.
Cloud Functions are
serverless methods
that can be called
directly with HTTP
or fired in response
to some other event.
In our case, every device
telemetry message coming in
fires the function which takes
the data from our hardware
and pushes it into
our storage option--
Cloud Firestore.
Firestore is a NoSQL database
with very low latency,
and for our purposes, a special
sauce, which is that it also
has a push update mechanism.
So our front end can
subscribe to data updates
and draw our incoming
telemetry data in real time.
So a quick recap
within the recap.
This setup alone would be useful
in terms of gathering data
for future use.
We've gone from device,
through IoT Core, to Pub/Sub,
and used a Cloud Function
to pull that telemetry data
into Cloud Firestore.
So what about visualization?
Yeah, let me explain.
No, there's too much.
Let me sum up.
We built two front
ends-- one in Angular
to show off how
easy it is to use
our batteries-included
JavaScript
framework to visualize
real-time streaming data,
and the other using Google
Sheets backed by Apps Script
to show off you a
raw-time windowed data.
We also created a couple
of administrative tabs.
One enabled us to configure
metadata in Firestore,
and the other hooked
up to IoT Core Admin
SDK, which allowed us to send
these configurations back
down to our devices
that we had built.
Obviously, there's
more than one way
to build an IoT application.
I've run through just the
one happy path doing it here
and the products involved.
In our session at
Cloud Next, we built
this entire end-to-end
application while on stage
as I talked through what
some of the other choices
are in Google Cloud Platform
and showed off some of the code
that we were writing
while on stage.
I even ran around the room while
attached to our sensor device
to get some more
interesting data.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link
in the description
below, and don't forget to
subscribe to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]